Let's get started.
We're going to keep talking
about polymers today.
Polymers-- that's also going
to be the topic of the quiz.
And because of the exam
and everything-- and so
we're having our second
lecture on polymers today.
The quiz tomorrow will be
at the end of recitation
so that you can have a
full second recitation
on this topic.
OK.
I mentioned this
on Monday, right?
Monday we introduced
polymers and I
covered two different
ways to make polymers, OK?
Let's write those down.
Let's write those down with
chalk, which is somewhere.
Here we go.
On the one hand, we had what
we called radical initiation.
So we use a radical initiator.
Remember this R dot?
And we talked
about radicals, OK?
And how that can lead to
this kind of chain reaction.
Right?
And so this is called
chain polymerization.
Sometimes it's called
addition, polymerization.
But it all involves
a radical to start it
and then a double bond.
Remember, we talked
about that double bond.
The importance of
the double bond.
Right.
So this would have some monomer.
This would have some monomer.
But it's got to have
with a double bond.
That's not an equal sign,
that's a double bond.
Now, the second
way we talked about
was called condensation
polymerization.
So condensation
polymerization these
are two ways we covered that
allow you to make these really,
really long chains.
That's what a polymer is, right?
Polymer-- "mer" being
from say hundreds
to thousands and even millions.
And in condensation
polymerization,
you would have two different--
you could even have more.
--monomers.
And these two different
monomers, well,
let's write it explicitly.
They react, OK?
And they react because
they've got these end groups
that when they see
each other, right,
from one monomer to the
next, they form a bond.
And in the case that
we did on Monday,
they formed an amide bond.
And they gave off water, right?
So water left.
So when you do condensation
polymerization,
you start with two
different monomers.
They've got the
end groups on them
that when they see each
other, they want to react.
You wind up with a polymer
that weighs a little bit less
than the two monomers, right?
Because you've given off water.
You could give off other things.
There's a lot of examples.
So in the reaction you give
off maybe H2O, like we did.
Could be HCL.
Could be NH3.
There are a number of ways.
I don't want you
to get the feeling
that the only way you can do
condensation polymerization
is the nylon example, all right?
There's a lot of
ways you can do this.
But one thing that
is certainly true
is that in forming that bond,
you give something else up.
And that's why sometimes people
like calling this addition.
Because in addition
polymerization,
right, you take a monomer
and you just keep adding it.
And the sum is n times
the monomer, right?
The sum of the weight.
Whereas in this case,
it's a little bit less
because you did a reaction.
OK.
So that's all kind of
getting us back in the mood.
That's what we did on Monday.
Now today, I want to talk about
the properties of polymers
and how we control them.
How we can change them.
Different ways that
we can change them.
I can't cover
everything but I want
to cover some key elements
of engineering polymers.
So we're going to talk
about the properties
and a couple of specific things
that we use to control them.
So let's start a list
here in the middle.
And the first thing is
something we already
did talk about Monday, which is
just the monomer itself, right?
So what is it that
matters in a polymer?
What is it that dictates what
a polymer will be like, right?
Well, one is the monomer.
So that's the unit--
well, OK.
We just said that
you need two here.
So maybe there's monomers.
But that's the unit
that you're repeating.
Clearly that's going to be
really important, right?
What did you put there, right?
Is it C2H4?
Is it polyethylene or
is it something else?
Did you add something to it?
The benzene ring, right?
And so that's going to
be really important.
The other thing that
we talked about--
and so we're going to
create this list --is
the molecular weight.
Now remember, molecular weight.
Oh we, like every
little community,
likes to come up
with its own names.
We know grams per mole.
And then they say,
oh that's a dalton.
And so now we have to say, OK,
a dalton is a gram per mole.
Kilodalton would be
1,000 grams per mole.
But we also said
that this gives us
the degree of polymerization.
So that's really
important, right?
Because how much to the
degree of polarization--
I mean, if I know
what my mer is and I
know the molecular weight, the
grams per mole of a strand,
then I know how many
mers went into it.
So I know the degree
of polymerization.
That's just n, right?
It's some number.
But this is important
and I'll put it over here
so I can keep going
down on that board.
When you have a
synthesis of a polymer,
doesn't matter which
one of those you use,
you're going out 100,000 units.
Yeah, I can't say
well, every single one
is going to be 100,000.
That is really,
really hard to do.
So instead you get
a distribution.
So when you say the
molecular weight, what you
mean is some average, right?
So this would be like maybe
the molecular weight, maybe
this is in daltons, maybe
it's in kilodaltons.
And you say, aw, the molecular
weight is 40 kilodaltons.
No, that's the average.
You might have ones that are
way, way longer out here.
Maybe orders of
magnitude longer.
This distribution can
be orders of magnitude.
But it still can
be you know, you
can try to make them longer so
you have a distribution that's
more out here.
Or you make them shorter, right?
So this is something
that is important
and that can be engineered.
You can imagine if my chains
are really, really long,
then maybe it's a
tougher material, right?
Because there's just more
covalently bonded backbone
to break, right?
You can imagine that
that might be one thing.
Oh, but the thing that
we gotta talk about
is the chemistry which
dictates the bonding.
OK, so the chemistry.
So the interactions.
And this takes us back
to so many happy moments
from this fall where we talked
about intermolecular forces.
All of those apply to polymers.
They all apply.
What are the IMFs?
Well, if I gave you an
example, like a question--
OK, maybe you could
say, well, let's see--
OK, I've got polyethylene.
Remember, this how we write it?
And in this case,
I've left off my Hs.
But the little sticks
there means there's
an H above and below each one.
I've got polystyrene.
So that's polyethylene.
Here's polystyrene.
Remember, this one
has a benzene ring.
Oh, that's a terrible
drawing of a benzene ring.
But it's what it's
supposed to be.
They have to come out
of the parentheses.
If it doesn't come
out of the parentheses
is not a polymer because you're
not indicating repetition,
right?
OK, that's supposed
to be benzene.
And that'll be polystyrene.
And then how about another one?
I'll put it here.
How about polyvinyl alcohol?
So now watch this.
I'm going brackets
because remember, it's OK.
And so here OH, right?
And each one of these would
have some number of repeats.
That's polyvinyl alcohol.
I can say well, just
look at those monomers.
Just look at the mers, right?
Remember, the
monomers if these were
made with chain polarization,
the monomers would
have a double bond, right?
Remember that.
But so this is the repeat
unit in the polymer.
That's what goes into the
brackets or the parentheses.
I can look at it and
say, which one of these
is going to be the
strongest mechanically?
And you know from your IMF days.
You know which one it is
because only one of them
can form a stronger
bond than London.
They're all going
to have London.
Everyone has London.
But this one has
hydrogen as well.
That's got hydrogen bonds.
So the polyvinyl alcohol
will be stronger, right?
That will be the stronger one.
And you know that bond
is going to be in there.
It's going to bond to other
hydrogens from other chains
or maybe from itself.
Because remember this
is what it looks like.
But even much, much,
much, much, much more.
These are macromolecules.
OK.
Yes.
But now I wanted to put
these here so I had them.
So I'm going to
take one of these.
Which one is it?
It's polystyrene.
It's this one with the very
poorly drawn benzene ring. .
And I didn't change
anything about it
but look at what it can do.
That's polystyrene in
three different forms.
They're all cups but you
know these cups well, right?
One's Styrofoam.
One, I don't know
what you call that.
But they're all
plastic cups but they
have very different properties.
They have the
exact same polymer.
Polystyrene.
How do we do that?
That's not the IMFs.
It doesn't even have
to have anything
to do with a molecular weight.
It could.
No, it's something else.
And that is the density.
Oh and so now we get
to talk about density
and crystallinity.
And I just saved three letters.
Makes me very happy.
Now crystallinity
density, memories.
Good memories.
Very good memories are
happening right now
from when we talked
about amorphous materials
and the glass transition, right?
Because remember, I
drew this on the board.
Let's see.
Let's get these to come down.
What that actually looks like--
each strand in there,
remember, goes like this.
And then it's like, oh wait.
I can make a crystal.
And then it's like, nope.
I'm amorphous again.
And then it's like oh wait.
Hold on.
I can crystallize right here.
And then it's amorphous
again and it's so fun.
And then you go
like this and that.
And that's like one one
hundredth of a strand.
And so you know the
crystalline region--
what do I mean by "crystalline?"
Well, the strand is
stacking up in some
ordered regular repeating way.
What do I mean by "amorphous?"
Well, I mean spaghetti.
But a polymer, in
its own strand,
can crystallize to some extent
or to more or less, right?
And that's something
we can control.
We can engineer that.
And that's what leads
to these differences
because you know that
in a crystalline region,
it's going to have a
lower volume, right?
It's going to take
up less volume.
That's what we did
before with glasses.
So let's put that
on the board, right?
So you know that from
out good old days
that if I melt a material,
well, it could form a crystal.
That's temperature.
And this would be
volume per mole.
Right, this would be
like the melting point.
It might form a crystal.
But with polymers, imagine
I've got the spaghetti strands
and now they're miles long.
It's really hard
to line it all up.
And so a lot of it will
not find that place.
And instead it will
be a glass, which
you know is another way of
saying so these are now TGs,
right?
TG.
And so you know now
all about this, right?
And you know that
cooling rate is
one way to change the density.
To change the volume
per mole, right?
So the density of
the amorphous region
is one parameter that could
be glassy in different ways,
like we did before.
And then how much of it
you can make into a crystal
is another parameter.
Both of which play into
the overall density
and crystallinity, right?
Both of those are
extremely important
and those are going to depend on
all sorts of parameters related
to the processing and the
temperature and so forth.
Those are the things that
can lead to changes like this
from the same exact chemistry.
So let's go from polystyrene
back to polyethylene.
So if you look at polyethylene--
so this is a list.
I showed I think a
version of this on Monday.
It's hard to read.
Don't worry about it.
These are all monomers.
And this is the polymer.
They didn't put
the brackets there
but you can see--
oh maybe they did.
Yeah sort of.
You can see the line,
right, coming out.
That's the repeat line.
And this is the monomer.
Notice the double bonds ready
for chain polymerization.
And here are the properties
and here are the uses.
Look at this-- LDPE and HDPE.
Now LDPE and HDPE.
So that's low density
and high density
of the same exact polymer.
So the interactions
are the same.
But all we've done is
we've changed the density
and the difference between
the properties is tremendous.
So when you go to
the grocery store
and they give you a plastic bag,
which you'll wind up feeding
to fishes in the ocean as
you now know, it's very soft.
It's the exact same
material that's
in over 30% of all
toys on the planet.
It's still polyethylene.
All we've done is
mess with that.
We've messed with the density.
So how do you mess
with the density?
How?
Well, it turns out
with polymers there are
different ways you can do this.
One we just talked about.
So one, let's do a little--
I'm going to do this.
So one would be
let's say processing.
I'll call it processing.
That's right here.
How quickly did I melt it?
What were the conditions
that I formed it in?
But see you can imagine
changing its ability
to crystallize our pack
by just changing something
else about the polymer itself.
And so another way
to do that would
be to change the physical
structure of the chain.
Physical structure.
And there are two ways
that you can do this.
Oh boy, let's see.
How am I going to continue this?
OK let's do this.
Bullet one.
One way is called branching.
And another is called tacticity.
So what are these?
So branching is exactly what it
sounds like because the polymer
I showed you here--
this is a mess and it's showing
how it's a spaghetti chain.
But notice that it's
just a line everywhere.
We would call this
a straight line.
This is a straight line, it
just kind of wanders around.
Yeah.
OK.
Because it's in contrast to--
if it's a straight line, then
it's sort of locally straight.
But what if it did this?
And then it's like,
well, which way do I go?
You can be the
exact same chemistry
but because maybe one of those
radicals in the soup while this
was being made came in and
got to move a hydrogen around
in just the right way.
It was able to start growing
off of the side, right?
That's a branch.
So you can imagine that
controlling this branching
would be a really
big deal in terms
of the crystallinity right?
So now if you go to pasta.
It always seems to
come back to pasta.
Maybe it's just me.
I don't think so though.
I think there's something
deep about the pasta in here.
But see, this is a polymer.
But you can imagine
now if I make spaghetti
and it looks like the
left, it's all packed in.
This is actually an interesting
idea for a new pasta brand,
right?
And what if each spaghetti
strand looked like that?
And now you take those
and you try to make your--
it would be actually pretty cool
but it wouldn't pack as well.
You can feel it with
the pasta, right?
You can feel it.
It's going to take up
more room in the bowl.
I mean, it's the exact
same thing with polymers.
So if you want a
polymer to be stronger,
to have maybe more
crystallinity or higher density,
HDPE, then you don't
want very much branching.
So you better dial that in.
When you synthesize
it, you better
think carefully about
how you're making
this to prevent those kinds of
side chains from growing, OK?
Well, tacticity
is another thing.
And that's not the
same as branching.
Tacticity is remember-- ah!
Where did it go?
I had it up there.
There's the benzene ring.
Are they all on the same side or
are they on alternating sides?
How did this thing go?
Did two go on the same side
and then one and is it random?
I mean, you can imagine
that if I have a way
to break the symmetry
of the chain like this,
then you can imagine that if I
break it a lot so I'm atactic,
then that's going to be
harder to line up as well.
That's going to make it
harder for the spaghetti
to kind of fall right
next to each other.
But even if this
spaghetti had little
you can call these little,
mini benzine branches.
It's not branching.
But you can call
them little branches.
But if they're all
on the same side,
then you can imagine they
can still stack really well.
So when you have side
groups like this,
this is another aspect of
engineering the polymer
that you got to think
very carefully about.
Because if it's isotactic
or syndiotactic,
then it's going to be--
so that's the physical
structure of the chain.
--then it's going to be
able to pack more easily
and it's going to
be stronger, right?
if it's atactic and we're
talking about like a hundred
degrees.
Same polymer, same chemical
unit make the molecular weights
the same.
All you've changed is whether
there's symmetry or not.
And you can change the melting
point by a hundred degrees.
Right, of the same material.
So that's another
way that we engineer
the properties of polymers, OK?
Same polymer garbage
bags to Tupperware.
Same chemistry.
Isotactic to atactic.
OK, now we get to
something really fun,
which is cross-links.
And this is number five, OK?
So we're talking about
ways to control polymers.
Cross-linking is one of the
single most important ways
to engineer the
properties of polymers.
And it basically
is exactly what it
says-- you're linking
two different polymer
chains together across.
Cross linking, OK?
Now, it turns out
the one-- remember,
I showed you the
video of the nylon.
It's called the nylon rope pole.
If you want to see
that again, Google it.
It's so cool.
You have two liquids
with the two--
it's a condensation
polymerization example.
Two liquids with two
different monomers and you
pull a solid out
of the interface.
And that's this.
That's exactly this.
And those are the
molecules, these
are the monomers that
were in the liquid.
And there is nylon 6.6.
Remember, it's because
you have a chain there.
And this is what you get.
And it keeps repeating.
And there's your polymer.
The reason I'm saying that
nylon actually cross-links
is because it's
something very important.
It's not just that these
have different interactions
with each other.
No.
It's something a little
bit more than that.
So if I look at this and
say, OK, here's a carbon
and a nitrogen. I'm
going to just try
to draw a part of this.
Carbon, nitrogen,
there's a hydrogen,
and oh boy, here we go.
Here's an oxygen. OK.
And it goes on.
Oh, I'm not going to
draw what's in there.
It's 6.6.
And then comes another.
OK, nitrogen,
hydrogen, and then it
goes up to a carbon,
oxygen, and then ah, 6.6.
Or whatever it is, right?
And then it goes to
a carbon and oxygen.
This should have been like that.
And this goes to nitrogen
and so on and so on.
Oh remember, this is
called the amide bond.
That's cool, right?
That's the bond that formed.
That's the amide bond.
That's the bond that formed
this polyamide, right?
We did this on Monday.
But look at what happened.
So if I have
another one of these
that comes up beneath
it-- and I'm not
going to draw the whole thing.
I'm just going to draw that
part that has the amide bond.
You can see that if I have an
oxygen here with the carbon
and let's do oh boy,
nitrogen, and like that OK?
And so on, then
if this lines up--
but it can line up.
And then over here
you've got a hydrogen.
And so you can get this
kind of really nice line
up to form a hydrogen
bond between these chains.
You can.
It can happen.
And that can add, as we
know, that can add strength
to the material.
So that's a cross link because
it's a very specific linkage
between these strands, right?
It's not just sort of an
average over different types
of bonding.
It's the specific link
that's in the chain.
Well, it turns out that
that just seemed to happen.
Because of the chemistry
that was there it can happen.
But look, we can
also make it happen.
We can engineer
polymers and we do
to have all sorts of
cross-linking chemistry.
And it's really one of the
most single important ways
to control the properties
of polymers, right?
So I want to talk about
that a little bit.
And I'm going to
do it with maybe
the most well-used, at
least, example of what
a cross-linker does.
We're going to
talk about rubber.
Now, rubber is a
natural polymer.
You can get it out
of trees, right?
I think maybe I have a picture.
Yeah, I do.
Oh, poor Goodyear.
But we'll talk about
him in a minute.
There's rubber coming
right out of a tree.
And when we see rubber in this
class we think of isoprene.
And isoprene is
this molecule, OK?
So here's isoprene.
There's a CH3 and then
there's a double bond
to a CH2 and another
double bond to another CH2.
Now, the polymer that is coming
from this rubber tree is what?
It's polyisoprene, OK?
So I've got two double bonds.
We're going to talk
about that in a second.
But I only need one
to polymerize this.
I only need one, right?
And so if I think about this,
I can make a polymer out of it
and the polymer
would look like this.
This would be polyisoprene, OK?
So H, I'll draw the Hs
in just so we keep track.
Here's another C.
And this has my--
oh boy.
I said I'd draw them
and now I have to.
Once you commit, all
right, there it is.
H, right?
And then you've got the
double bond in there.
And an H there.
And then you've got
this CH2 unit there.
Oh, and that is polyisoprene.
It's not-- it looks complicated.
It's got a CH3 unit
and some CH2 units.
But here's the key--
it's got left over,
a double bond.
All right, that's the key.
Now, you see, that double bond,
I can do more chemistry with.
I can do cross-link
chemistry with.
So I started with two
and I'm left with one
because I needed one
to make the 100,000
long chains of these things,
right so this is isoprene.
And this is polyisoprene.
Yeah, but the thing is
that polyisoprene is not
very useful.
The Mayans used it.
People tried to use
polyisoprene directly
from nature for centuries.
The Mayans would because
it's soft, you know?
It's like a mold.
It's this really cool mold.
And probably, at some point,
somebody stepped in it.
And they're like,
look, my footprint.
And it stayed.
And so then, what they did
is they made boots out of it.
And so they would
put their whole foot
inside of bucket of isoprene.
and then it would sort of
mold really well, right?
And they'd make shoes that way.
The problem is people tried
to do this much later too.
The problem with making a
boot out of natural rubber
is that the natural rubber
doesn't hold together
very well.
So like seriously, on
a hot day, the boot
melts, which is
not what you want.
People made clothing
out of it too.
Jackets were made with
polyisoprene inside
of two fibers.
But then it would melt and get
like sticky, like, on a summer
day or if it rained out.
So you had some
issues with rubber.
But people really wanted to make
something out of this stuff.
It seemed really neat.
It could kind of be strong
but then very moldable.
And so along comes
Charles Goodyear.
And he accidentally left rubber
on his stove with sulfur.
And literally, the
way the story goes
is his house started smelling
like burnt rubber, which
was probably the first time
ever that smell was made.
And what he found was that this
rubber was completely different
when it was left on
the stove with sulfur.
It all comes back
to the double bond.
Why?
Because now I've
got a place where
I can add a covalent link.
And that's exactly what
sulfur does, all right?
So if I take this--
I'll try to draw it again.
I'm not going to draw
the Hs this time.
So I've got this and here's
that special double bond, right?
And then I've got this and this.
OK, that's natural rubber.
But now see, with
a double bond, I
can-- remember, what are these?
Well, these are four electrons?
But if sulfur comes
along, I might
be able to take two of them
and move them like this.
If sulfur comes and
offers something
that the carbon wants.
Hey, come and bond with me.
It'll be more fun.
Maybe we'll go to a lower
energy state, right?
And then the carbon's
like, you know what?
I get that.
That sounds pretty cool.
I'm going to give an electron
from this double bond.
I get to stay connected here
with a single bond, right?
And then I can be here
and here and the sulfur
can provide that other electron
and form a nice single bond,
right?
Because there's
that double bond,
you can do the chemistry to
create covalent strong bonds
to sulfur.
And then you get like, another
sulfur and another sulfur
and so on and these can be
maybe 2, 3, 4 sulfur units long,
depending on how you cook it.
And then this will come.
And this comes down
and finds another one,
finds another strand.
And it finds the
double bond that's
in another polyisoprene strand.
That's called cross--
that's well, accidental.
He was a tinkerer.
And he played with
lots of things.
And his greatest discovery
was completely by accident.
And he never made
any money off of it.
Goodyear Tire, this
is Charles Goodyear.
Goodyear tires,
this is the company.
It was called the Goodyear
Vulcanite Company.
Goodyear called
it vulcanization.
And the reason is Vulcan
is the Roman god for fire.
And he accidentally
left it on the fire.
And so that's called
vulcanization because of that.
So this used to be the
Goodyear Vulcanite Company.
It's now Goodyear Tires, right?
And what happened?
What happened is
this low sulfur bonds
that came about accidentally,
the covalent bonds,
held that material together.
And it gave it a controllable
flexibility and hardness right?
That's what they were after.
That's what they were after--
flexibility and hardness.
And so what is actually
happening in this?
Well, what's happening
is you're adding
these covalent bonds between
these very, very long
strands, right?
And so you can imagine that if
you pull on that material now,
well, the long
strands can detangle.
So in the rubber tree, these
long, long, long, long strands,
they're all wrapped up.
It's a spaghetti bowl.
And I start pulling.
And they don't break
but they start to kind
of slide and detangle, right?
And eventually, you
just break it all apart.
But now, I've got a lock on
it because each little piece
of spaghetti is tied to
another one somewhere.
So I can untangle
them only to a point.
And then these linkages kick in.
And they're like, no I'm sorry.
You can't stretch
anymore, right?
That's what the crossing does,
it gives it that strength.
And so you can imagine, if I
had more and more cross-linking,
I might have a stronger
material, right?
The stress strain curve
could go like that.
Not much cross-linking.
A lot of cross-linking, right?
Because more and
more of it is going
to be dictated by these linkages
here between the strands.
And then there's
something really cool
that can happen with
cross-linking because this is
an example of a covalent bond.
This is covalent.
But cross-linking can be--
let's see, it can be
covalent, it can be hydrogen.
We already saw that there's
sort of natural cross-linking
in nylon because of
that hydrogen bond.
You can introduce
hydrogen bonds as well.
You can be purposeful about it.
By the way, you can have ionic--
you can put any kind of
bonding that you can dial in,
and there are different
ways to do that,
can become a cross-link
opportunity, right?
So you can just imagine how much
this opened up polymer design.
How much this cross-linking
opens up polymer design.
Now, there's a downside as well.
But first, let's say positive.
Let's go to your goody bag.
This is the chemistry inside
your goody bag, right?
Now, this is a very purposeful.
Right, these are the
Borax cross-linkers
you've got that in your
bag and you add it in.
And what I want you to do
is get an actual feeling
for the cross-linkers, right?
And so you can add
more and you'll
feel the material
change because you're
linking more and more of it.
But see, in this case,
it's a hydrogen bond.
You see that?
See, those are the
Borax cross-linkers.
Those groups keep their
OHs and then those OHs,
there's the polyvinyl alcohol.
I drew that on the board
somewhere before and those
OHs can now bond to the
hydrogen or the OH and the PBA
and that can form a cross-link.
But there's something
different about this one
and it's so cool.
And that's why slime is so
cool and Silly Putty, right?
Because now there is
a timescale involved.
There's a timescale involved.
So now you can
pull it very slowly
and the hydrogen bonds
that are cross-linking
haven't have time to
change, to move, to reform.
Yeah, they break and
then they reform, right?
But if you pull it really
fast, those hydrogen bonds
don't have time, right?
And I'll show you a
picture in a second.
And so what can happen now
is the mechanical strength
of this material, the
brittleness of it.
The properties of it
can literally just
depend on how
quickly you pull it.
Because you are up against
the speed of hydrogen bond
forming and reforming.
And that is incredibly cool.
You are literally feeling the
formation, the destruction
and formation of hydrogen bonds.
But there's
something else that's
going on in this
that's also so cool.
This material, slime, that
polymer is below its glass
transition temperature.
Sorry, above.
I meant above.
What does that mean?
It means that without
the cross-linkers,
that polymer is
a viscous liquid.
We drew it somewhere.
I erased it?
I erased it.
If you're below the ground the
glass transition temperature,
you're basically a solid,
like a brittle solid.
Well, like I drew, polymers
are amorphous, maybe
with some crystalinity but a lot
of it's going to be amorphous.
Maybe all of it.
And so it's going to have a
glass transition temperature
and if you're above that,
it's this viscous liquid.
It's this like super
cooled viscous liquid.
But what I've done
with the cross-linkers
is I've said hold on.
You can't go away.
So I'm literally making
a solid out of liquid.
We say yeah, just put
like, water in the freezer.
No, that's not-- the phase
of that polymer is liquid.
It is a viscous liquid.
But it is not allowed
to flow or if it does,
it maybe can change
its shape a little.
Bit it can't just flow
all over the place because
of those cross-links, right?
And that's an elastomer.
And if you do it just right,
you get a viscal material.
And what do I mean by that?
Well, all these things
have to line up, right?
The thing has to want
to be a liquid so it's
got to have the right glass
transition temperature.
But the cross-linkers are
sort of holding it in place.
And the cross-linker chemistry
has to be the right strength.
It can't be too strong,
can't be too weak, right?
And again, by accident, you
might make cross-link silicone.
Oh there's the goody bag,
which is Silly Putty.
And that's why I wanted to give
that to you because this hits
all the right combinations.
In this case, the backbone is
made out of silicon, right?
Not carbon.
But it's the same thing.
It's the cross-linking
that does this.
So there's an example of
Silly Putty, which you all
have the goody bag.
And if you stretch it slowly,
those hydrogen bonds--
the strands can
kind of pull away.
And those hydrogen bonds have
time to slowly form and reform.
That's why it kind
of feels the same.
Nice, elastic right?
Depending on the
material, on the backbone,
it might go back as well.
In Silly Putty, it
kind of just keeps
on-- those strands
just keep on sliding
and the hydrogen
bonds keep reforming.
But if instead I pull it
fast, the hydrogen bonds
don't have time to react.
That's why, if you
pull it really fast--
like OK, don't do this.
Somebody shot a
bullet through it.
It breaks like glass.
And you can feel it in your
hands, just pull really fast.
The hydrogen bonds don't
have time to reform, right?
And so what you're left
with is you're just
breaking apart this material.
Now, how elastic it feels,
right, how viscous it feels.
All these things,
these are going
to be determined by
the glass transition
temperature of the temperature
of the room, right?
And so that's going to depend
on whether you actually
have a very vicious liquid.
Or maybe you've
got a solid, then
it's going to be more brittle.
All of these things are
now at your disposal
to tune the properties
of the polymer, right?
They're all at your disposal.
And it's incredible to think
about, for me at least,
holding together a liquid
in place like that.
And that's leads
to viscoelasticity.
Viscoelasticity, right?
That's just viscous
liquid in elastic, right?
OK.
Now, there's a
couple more things
that we have to talk about.
And on Friday.
What I want to do Friday
is I want to come back
a little bit to some
of the ways that we're
trying to maybe
engineer polymers
to be more like nature, right?
We were talking
about Monday, if you
want to try to
solve the problems,
try to do something big.
And I gave an example of
an ocean cleanup project.
But the ocean cleanup
project wouldn't it
matter if we keep dumping more
and more plastic in the oceans
that doesn't degrade.
All right, so we have to think
very carefully about what
kinds of plastics we can make.
And the problem with
cross-linking-- this
gets to the negative
side, right?
And this is a way
of categorizing
these things that I've
been talking about
is if I cross-link it a lot,
we call that a thermoset.
We call that a thermostat.
Why?
Because when you heat it
up, "thermo," it's set.
So you mold it and then you've
got your little cross-linker.
You know, you pour
your sulfur in
and then it's got a very
high number of cross-links.
And you can see it there, right?
And it gives you
very strong material.
But you can't break
it back apart.
So it's very hard to recycle.
It's almost impossible.
If you try to heat these back
up, they just burn usually.
And if you melt them,
they're not usually
that useful because they've
got all this other chemistry
and it completely
messes with the polymer.
On the other hand,
a thermoplastic
has this kind of
plastic deformation.
Think maybe like a garbage bag.
So it can really stretch
and stretch and stretch.
But it doesn't have
the cross-linkers.
That's why you can do that.
And so this is actually much
easier, heat it up, melt it,
and you can reuse it.
So that's a recyclable polymer.
But the issue there
is it's very difficult
to get all of the necessary
mechanical properties
from these thermoplastics.
And so elastomers,
which are maybe
lightly cross-linked
polymers that
are above the glass
transition temperature often,
those are somewhere in between.
But most of the time, even
if you cross-link lightly,
it's very difficult to recycle.
And that's a really good
problem because maybe we
can come up with
cross-link chemistries that
are reversible, right?
They can give us an
opportunity to have
the best of both worlds.
It's elastic when we want.
It's deforms when we want
and it's solid when we want.
Oh and by the way, you can
degrade all those cross-links
and reuse it.
That's like one of the dreams in
making environmentally friendly
plastic.
See you guys on Friday.